your son is getting older uh you know
he's i feel like it was so dope to see
you guys do that oreo commercial yeah
he's way bigger than that now
now that like he's older he's kind of
like a little dude now you know what i
mean um
how do you do the work-life balance
because i feel like you do it so well
uh-huh because for me it's more about uh
spending time with him and making sure
he's good so i get i'll get the work out
of the way but i just schedule my life
to where if you know he's got a ton of
[ __ ] to do if i got stunning [ __ ] to do
around around him i just won't have a
lot of work stuff
like
when you
grind for
10 plus years and work every [ __ ] day
and like go to the studio every day or
go to every meeting or do every drop
at a certain point you get to not have
to do all of that [ __ ] like you get to
do it when you want to yeah you've
worked you've worked so hard up until
this point so where you can say yeah and
raps not my only
thing you know what i'm saying like i
got voiceovers i got a ton of other [ __ ]
that you know i'm making money off of or
my companies that make money that i
don't even have to physically show up
for so if i have companies that i don't
have to physically show up for that are
bringing me millions of dollars with
death i can spend a ton of time with my
son you know what i'm saying i've worked
for that yeah i
afforded myself that and i made sure
that you know i i
made that comfortability for myself a
lot of people don't think about that
[ __ ] they just think money money money
show show show blah blah blah all right
well how much money you're gonna make if
you don't go you know what i'm saying
and if you
and if it's none
you're not really a boss or you're not
really as paid as you think you are like
you got to get up and you got to go i'm
going to chill here with my son i think
the pandemic uh unfortunately a lot of
people realized i'm not as rich as i
thought i was because but that wasn't it
the li the live show [ __ ] people were
getting like [ __ ] fake money what do
you mean like no i mean in terms of
lambo's like [ __ ] no no no no
i mean i mean artists i mean artists oh
artists know artists know that they're
broke because they have people who tell
them they're broke they just keep
spitting money yeah yeah they just be
like no i got a show for 100k next week
so i'm good no brother you just spent
70k
right you're not good but they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] and they don't
they don't care about
balancing that out because it takes too
much time effort and energy did you have
you ever seen an artist [ __ ] off
their money that you were cool with like
a young guy and you pull them to the
side and be like every last one of them
and yes i talk to them i pull them to
the side yeah yep and do they listen no
[Laughter]
hell no yeah the pandemic was crazy
everyone i knew was like rich all of a
sudden yeah fake money i was like
everyone's got [ __ ] designer and yeah
fake ass money it's cr it's great and
now some of them are in prison
or or they're you know or pending see ya